[Music]
all right back to business here in armed
defense news defense news anyway
defense okay submitted by bought stream
oh thank you God a lot of Dreams out
from the actual dream of like something
probably one of my passions or goals
rapper bun be shot an armed intruder who
is trying to steal his wife's car that's
easy
Texas rapper rapper what parappa the
rapper will rap at the rap lab you
thought cutest buck oh you sound like
you're talking to tiger did ya you're
doing our bear language he he's in I
think he's a rapper from Texas yes nice
is Bumby wanna met him at the source
Awards
oh yeah cannot can I get some music from
bumpy who oh I don't know any of his
music I just know a reference of what of
him from the kindnesses what he looks
like
oh think that tells me jack but I was
about to tell you girl I was looking
through his music last night to see if I
recognize any of it and I did find
something that series with his wife
Queen
oh damn that's her name yeah damn I
didn't change my wiener Queenie I seen
both versions and articles so she makes
him cocky minute rash peasant you're
gonna name her peasant yeah
could be a pet humbler yeah I'm humble
in real quick so around 5:45 p.m. there
was a knock on their door so then the
wife opened it she was expecting a
delivery but it turned out to be a
masked man holding a gun and then so he
demanded her valuables and so she gave
him whatever she could and then offer it
up her outie that was in the garage
because she was said later that she was
just scared that they were trying to
target her husband so she was just
what a down-ass [ __ ] dude so then my
husband come in five minutes wait you
got the wrong person with nails on next
care my parents they're all my mama baby
alright so that's when bumpy was
upstairs that he heard all the commotion
so he pulled out his gun ran downstairs
saw the guy in the garage inside of the
Audi so he started shooting at him wait
did he shoot yes he did he shot he shot
him in his caught in the car he shot at
him and saw the guy somehow got away but
then later on he died later on he showed
up at a to a hospital of course with a
gun wound in his shoulder and that's
when they arrested him so now he has
been so he's charged with two counts of
aggravated robbery with a deadly weapon
one count of burglary and he's being
held on a 120 thousand dollar block you
live in Texas Houston that's tight
that's why son [ __ ] castle law son Wow
I don't think we could do that in
California absolutely throw in the car
running the garage already I was looking
at this car of the United States and
there's about 25 states where their law
says you have to retreat first before
you can resort to deadly force
California's been called like the the
Robin Hood law or some [ __ ] like that
what does Retreat mean like you have to
back off so you just have to run away
we're treating for California you have
to retreat and you have to go to a place
where you feel like there's no other way
you can go before you can return deadly
force but there's also 25 other states
where it's immediately if someone [ __ ]
with you you can immediately kill them
[ __ ] with you how I hope you like it
immediately kill you know this take one
more fry now [ __ ] take your wife one
nod yelp review yeah but if someone
approaches you with deadly force you can
immediately return but then the other 25
states you have to retreat first but
also there's also a lot of different
what is it like scales of that so the
exact same scenario depending on how it
plays out you can be innocent or guilty
depending on which state you go to it's
[ __ ] confusing yes but Wow
so a lot of like like cops if they
transfer States or like even people that
do carry weapons they're saying like you
really should memorize all the laws of
every single state and know how to play
the proceedings of all before you you
know go kill people yeah yeah there's a
case well maybe you should just kill the
person then like kill them cuz they
can't say [ __ ]
that's basically what odds in your favor
you know cuz like otherwise there's like
a bigger chance you just die right yeah
Dan that will miss down as [ __ ] though
dude she's decided to sacrifice the car
in order to save her husband dude what
the [ __ ] how is that [ __ ]
mind-blowing it's a [ __ ] cult you
would have rat out his husband of course
it certainly didn't do would have been
[ __ ] yeah I'm ready Laurie there dude on
the door loony gun I just said that was
I would have said immediately on a chair
like this find it strange that they that
he chose 5:45 in the PM rush hour
knocking on the front door in broad
daylight and it's still daylight
I don't think at any time in the year is
that not big white yeah yeah there's
still light out and that's when people
come home for dinner so you should do it
when people aren't home worst plan we
even got a winner because it's pretty
self so though I doubt if zombies coming
out with the new album oh you set it all
up yeah but the guys arrested he's in
jail yeah doesn't look sorry chin is so
high just try to pose for the mugshot
he's eight feet tall that's the only way
he's asking if you see any boogers in
his nose I'd like to think that the guy
got on the [ __ ] floor okay and his
nostrils are bigger than his eyes it's
full legit has Mario's nostrils dude he
took his mic shot and then so I mean he
sentenced to jail or I told you all the
county
oh yeah so you didn't go to trial yet
that's [ __ ] crazy man I was an idiot
yeah but luckily Lumbee and his wife
they were OC nothing no one got hurt
that's pretty bold
- you ready in any type of situation to
get robbed
who you guys like do you have a protocol
you don't get robbed my head but if I
don't if I'm not on my a game like if
I'm like just taking a [ __ ] or something
that might get caught - advantage I feel
like someone's got Robbie taking a [ __ ]
they'd be like a little bit thrown off
the roof things would be shot in this
situation nothing scares another man
than a naked man that's true unless
they're gay I know I know well I was gay
then you have some no not all gay guys
want to see gay guys no but they're
there there they won't be they won't be
like freaked out by a dick get freaked
out if of a naked girl comes at me but
whoa I mean I'm not gonna be scared cuz
you're not gay whoa you look so good
he's saying it from the perspective of a
dude is your diet a naked girl come Adam
we're not going to be like oh yeah there
was this fight like there was this like
worldstar video where two guys were
about to fight and it is guy took off
his [ __ ] pants and he threw his
boxers and his dick was wiggling and
yeah yeah if I was gonna fight someone
like you know actually happened are you
talking about yeah I don't think we have
a protocol thank you
well would you like to share you don't
want to talk about the protocol I'll put
it on you talk about it but we have one
but we have a lot of [ __ ] guns and
big scare no you know the camera all the
gun safes and everything yeah but
there's so many different codes I forgot
[Laughter]
yes only those it laggs elects huh a leg
no and it's not my finger sofa it's not
like an iPhone you can't put multiple
time you guys not home just you know get
some reconnaissance right now that is
pretty scary though
anyway luckily no one got
here and everyone's just except for the
bad guys I was like thought he got shot
well I mean no one important got hurt
okay and everyone's just praising bun be
like this [ __ ] dope what about the
wife no yeah and the way okay everyone
thanks that's all take the shoes like
stood by her man I mean all you had to
do is run down with a gun and shoot the
wife actually did all the scary [ __ ]
that's yeah being unarmed held up and
you're just like I gotta forgive in my
car you can pull the trigger like
nothing huh you could pull the trigger
like if there's a immediate threat yeah
I think I can oh yeah I I think being
scared will make me pull the trigger
person randomly yeah I'm more scared
that I might shoot people that are like
that friendly-fire
because I think just being scared what
make me just shoot so now we know if
they're gonna run away we're at the
shooting range you just like the line
behind [ __ ] Joe or just think oh [ __ ]
yeah I think so okay good to know
a year ago any survivors oh the one we
used to go to one of them someone died
their indoor indoor outdoor outdoor oh
[ __ ] there were some [ __ ] idiots that
word shooting over the brim and being an
idiot yeah they shot somebody killed
someone innocent like not even the guy
they went to jail for sure yeah yeah for
negligence and yeah
[Music]